♪ Am I weak ♪
♪ Or am I just playing it cool ♪
- [Governer] I don't see Dushane.
- No, ma'am.
He's been keeping an
extremely low profile.
- Dushane's very cagey, guv'nor.
No one even knows where he's living.
- Then we need to be
smarter then, don't we?
This guy shouldn't be on our streets.
(intense dance music)
(tape reel rewinding)
- Oh look, here we go.
The zombies are back again.
- Keep it down.
I told you don't fucking come around here.
- Can you just give us a hit, please?
- Where's your pea?
- He's got it.
- That ain't no fucking money, man.
- It's got Bluetooth.
- Everyone's got Bluetooth, cuz.
My ancestors have got Bluetooth.
Bring me something more interesting,
like an iPad or something.
- Can we just get two white, please?
C'mon, man, it's worth two.
- Fuck off!
- Don't even ask, I ain't
got fuck all for you.
- No, listen, man.
- Didn't you hear me,
fuck off, man!
- I got something
to tell you, innit?
- What?
- See that store where that
fella sells them lighters?
- What about it?
- He's police.
- What?
- We saw him.
We seen him, didn't we?
At the cop shop, he's Old Bill.
- He'll nick us, innit?
Said we was trying to
break into some house,
took his time throwing us into a nick.
They didn't have a thing on us, though,
'cause we hadn't even
fucking broken in to it.
- We were sitting in the
corridor in the nick,
and who walks past but him?
- They probably nicked him and all.
- No, he was laughing and joking
with the other coppers.
Like they was all mates.
- His name's Dave.
- Dave, yeah?
- That's what they were all calling him.
He's definitely a copper, man, trust me.
- Yeah, go on.
Fuck off.
- Looks like we've got a little spy.
- So what you wanna do?
- Better go chat to this brother.
The fuck do you lot want?
- Can you give us a hit?
- There ain't no food.
- C'mon, man, please.
- Listen to what I'm saying.
There ain't no fucking
food on the road right now.
- Even just like a little bit of weed?
Everyone's always got weed.
- We gave you the wink about
the undercover copper, didn't we?
- Go over there.
- So what, you lot got peas then?
- No, Woodrow said that
you'd tick us for it.
- Go, tick them for it.
- Go on then, fuck off.
- What the fuck's going on?
Where's the others?
- They ain't showed up.
- Hey yo, yous two, come here.
- Hey, get over here, man.
- Listen.
I know you lot trawl
round here a lot, innit.
Hey Farad, give them your number.
- [Farad] Bruv, pass your phone.
- Listen, it's simple.
You see Deshane, you
see Sully, you shout me.
Like I said, I got you.
- Yeah, all right.
- [Jamie] Ay yo, give
them something, innit.
- Thank you.
- Yo.
- [Dealer] The fuck are you
gonna do with them, bruv?
- [Junkie] Yeah?
- You lot wanna make some money, yeah?
- Yeah, of course.
- We'll do anything.
- All right, listen.
Go down the fields, yeah?
Keep your eyes and your ears open.
Anything you see or you
hear about Jamie's supply,
you let me know.
I got a hit for you.
- We won't let you down, man.
- What?
- Junkies, fam.
Really?
(ominous music)
- Right, come here.
Right, come on, let's go.
Do you reckon that's all right?
- No.
- No, more?
- Yeah.
- It's fucking cold.
- How long we supposed to
hang around the fields?
- Until we see something
that we can give Dris.
Something interesting.
- Hopefully.
- Shit.
- [Passerby] What'd you say?
- What?
- What's up with you?
- [Junkie] Nothing's up with me
- What are you fucking
doing around here anyway,
you shouldn't be around here anyway,
look at the state of the pair of you,
skanky pair of--
- Literally said
nothing to you.
- [Junkie] You walked into her, bro.
- Right bro, who you bro-ing?
What's it gotta do with you?
- Look, calm down--
- Fuck off.
- [Junkie] Oi!
- Listen, take your filthy junkie shit
and stay off this estate.
Do you understand me?
There's kids in here, man--
- Get off of him, leave him alone
- Sling your fucking hook.
- Just relax, Sarah!
It's all right.
Look, we're going, all right?
We're leaving, all right?
- Just so you understand,
don't let me catch you round here again,
and don't let my fucking kids
catch you around here again.
Do you understand me?
- I understand, mate.
I'm going, we're going.
- Fuck off.
- You all right?
Oi?
- I'm sick of this shit.
- I know.
Come on.